you play an acting coach I do unbury and
I'm curious because when the show first
started and I talked to you about this I
thought oh you're gonna play the inept
you know acting coach and what I've
loved is the subtlety of your character
gene is actually quite good he's
actually quite a good acting coach do
you have advice for actors if you could
be their coach
what would your real what happened we
will yield for Henry what would Henry
Winkler's advice to people be if they
want to be an actor honestly if someone
is sitting at home and and thinking
about being an actor I would be honest
about my ability I would train my
ability I would make sure that I have
worked on my tenacity and my gratitude
because I I've said this before tenacity
gets you where you want to go gratitude
doesn't allow you to be angry on the
journey and then when the time is right
I would get up and grab life by the
horns because I am living proof there is
there is a chair for you at the table if
you have really taken care otherwise you
could be a flash in the pan and and then
you will feel bad I think a lot of
people too in this business they have
some success but then it's over and this
is gonna be surprising to a lot of
people watching this show they look at
anyone on TV and think oh they're their
dreams came true everything's great
right they don't realize how many people
are angry and bitter right how did you
deal with that at times when you say
didn't win the Emmy or were up for a job
and didn't get it how do you deal with
the anger do you know um when I was in
drama school honestly I I thought oh my
god people are graduating they're
leaving they're going to New York
they're getting those jobs they're
taking a job there's not a job for me
and what I finally realized is that
there is if you're meant to be there
there is something for you
also yeah uh and III I just always
thought it was not meant to be all right
I'm not gonna work for you then I'm
going to get up and I'm gonna go over
here oh I'm not gonna work for you then
I'm gonna get up I'm gonna go over there
I got the job right right so just like a
weeble wobble you know you knocked me
over
come right back to Center cuz you know
what I just I got the word five minutes
ago you've been fired from berry it does
not surprise
[Laughter]